[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
ryan's here ryan's always here
these days yeah well thank god thank god
i mean i can't talk to myself
anymore dude any longer any longer any
longer
you know and i've talked about my dog
but i definitely had a little bit of a
breakdown today
um because you know my friends are
always like you're such a good dog dad
and look he gives him such great
treatment and i'm like
and i'm like going i'm not a great
[ __ ] dog dad
sometimes i feel like i'm just not
because the dogs that you know
irv is is really old now dogs of his age
lived
uh type breed lived till 10 to 12. he's
really 13. he almost died five months
ago he was going to five doctors a week
i have ptsd i'm carrying this 80 pound
dog
up the stairs to poop outside eight to
ten times a day
hoping if he'll [ __ ] i will at least
oh thank god he took a [ __ ] maybe now it
won't be all over the house or him
and i uh obviously relate to him because
i'm like poor son of a gun man i love
this guy
but at the same time i'm like well he's
you know he doesn't walk real well
uh jess my former assistant who also
still helps me out she had a breakdown
we both had a cry the other day or
couldn't even walk and then the next day
he's kind of walking better and
it's just this constant i'm just
living in anxiety with him and so i
he's suffering obviously way more than i
am i don't think he realizes he's
suffering
that's what they say about dogs maybe
because he's not any pain i don't i
believe
he was in pain i'd i'd shut it off if
you're in pain buddy and i can't fix it
you're not gonna live in pain
you're gone i'm not gonna be that cruel
but it gets to a point where i had a
breakdown this morning where
i'm just like what the [ __ ] i i don't
know i mean getting 10 pills a day
twice a day and and just you know and
it's just a lot it's a lot it's a lot
for the owner it's a lot for the dog and
the dog
i feel terrible about little irvey and
uh
you know but i look at myself if i go if
if one day some
i i just can't walk it's different for a
human
i could tell you what i want i can't
walk
carry me to the kitchen and feed me you
know it's it's a little different but
if it gets to a point where that's just
the apathy kicks in where i'm not
getting up to go eat
i'm not taking my pills i'm not
then i have to start thinking because
i'm already starting to think about it
i'm like
he's not in any pain but does that mean
because he's not in pain he should just
lie there all day and not exercise and
not be able to do things how much
could i do so there comes a point where
i
my stutter there
where i just have to make a decision and
and uh i i don't like it i don't like
decisions
in general um any advice on all this
ryan i know i'm throwing a lot at you
in fact yesterday we were doing a
podcast and you said to me you okay
and i said why i don't know he just
seemed a little off today and i was off
man i was
what did you notice about me uh you your
eyes were not
open fully and um yeah
well you usually wear hats but you were
wearing a hat and so your hair was kind
of a mess
but you hadn't slept and you've been
dealing with whatever
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah have you
have you ever had to put down a dog no
i haven't and uh but i know that i would
have put down my grandfather years
before he passed
yeah i know if they were giving me that
choice
my grandfather was a brilliant mind and
he was
he didn't know where he was who he was
uh you know the incontinence starts
and you know i'm like this guy is a
[ __ ] brilliant awesome dude i love
him he's like my best friend of the
world
i said tom to my best friend tom lally i
said lally
i will [ __ ] come and haunt you and
everybody you know if you don't [ __ ]
put me down
if you don't find a way to euthanize me
i will
[ __ ] terrorize you in your dreams
freddy krueger style
tina this is gone
all right i mean yeah i haven't have you
put down a dog
uh i've had dog i haven't been there
when it's happened but i've had
to deal with losing dogs a few dogs
already in my life
and it's it's tough i mean yeah
because my usually my mom was the one
who's taking care of him and she'd take
him on long walks and uh
it was rough for her the first uh i mean
every time every time it's rough
yeah and every dog is different because
every dog you know
brings something new to the table and um
they give you nothing but good times
even when they're being pains in the ass
but they are um a positive force
all the time and then you know it's true
that is true
it is a positive thing i i there's
nothing
that i love more than to lie on his bed
because he's i got to do these two giant
orthopedic beds for him to be
comfortable
yeah and then just lie there and take a
nap with him and pet him and
uh but he seems a little miserable he
just seems like
sometimes he's kind of like tries to
play
but most of the time he's just like this
kind of sucks man
i did uh have to take
my girlfriend's cat to
uh he was having a really rough time uh
he was not walking he was not you know
eating
eating and she held on as long as she
could and she really did not want to
take him in
and there was a point where it was just
it was too hard it was
crushing her it was crushing me it was
crushing the cat just
being alive so we took it
it was just one morning we were up all
night with the cat and uh
it was inevitable and we took it
i drove it to uh the animal hospital and
it
it died in our arms in the car are you
serious
yeah you got a little emotional just
saying that right there right yeah it's
one of those things that i try not to
think about well sense memory you know
it's like you think so
well how great is that in a way how
[ __ ] up is that but like
you didn't have to go euthanize them but
the cat just dies in your arms yep
he just he just went on the way to the
hospital when we knew we had to take him
oh
i kept thinking you should have put on
that song in the car which was to make
you guys i would do something like that
to make myself laugh
just to try i i just died in your arms
tonight
anyway uh i hope everybody had a a
pleasant weekend
um sorry for burning burdening you with
all of this but i don't i think you know
this is what we talk about on this show
and i think uh
you could either fast forward to the
guest or you could listen and have some
insight into
what's happening in our lives uh the the
band
sunspin um i want you to know we're
doing a pretty cool giveaway with the
release of our new album which is called
best days the band of sun spin
the album's best days if you want to
support the band and win some sweet
sweet swag head over to sunspin band on
instagram
just type in sun spin band on instagram
and this is only it's only going to last
for uh the next couple of weeks so make
sure you check it out today
we have a post that explains everything
so head over to sunspin band
on instagram and if you want to book the
band or buy merch go to sunspin.com
and uh yeah but uh sunspinbin on
instagram will tell you everything you
can to win
some some some sweet swag also
sunspin we got a a show coming up on
stage it go to stageit.com type in sun
spin we've got two shows
february 27th 2 p.m pacific standard
time and 6 p.m pacific standard time
so we're going to be playing covers jams
you win prizes
zooms uh people win zoom calls we zoom
after the shows
it's great please grab a ticket join us
february 27th 2 p.m and 6 p.m pacific
standard time
uh sun spin you can also go to
sunspin.com
and find out all the information you
need
and thanks for listening to inside the
podcast if those of you those of you who
are listening for the first time
if you enjoy the podcast i'd love for
you to subscribe on youtube and
on uh apple podcast or whatever wherever
you listen ryan
uh inside of you pod on the twitters uh
at insideable podcast
on instagram and facebook that's true
and um also the inside of you online
store for awesome merch
like uh look at this i haven't even put
this out yet or maybe it's out now it's
inside of you beanie yep and we got uh
inside you shirts with my face on it
coming we got uh
uh some uh i saw some kid wearing a
shirt that said
michael rose mom is the best lex luthor
ever fight me
and i go i'm making that that's awesome
actually a lot of people were asking to
make one so i said sure so uh those have
been
flying off the shelves but if you want
to listen to
inside of you or follow us it really
helps write a review on apple podcast
you do not know how much if you really
enjoy today
write a review and that goes a long way
it bumps us up in the rankings and all
that and spread the word to your friends
and what's the
handles for inside of you i did that
already you did i did i'm out of my mind
so you could also go to youtube.com
inside of you with michael rosenbaum and
subscribe to the youtube channel
that is true we've got a great guest
today um it was nice to catch up with
her
she uh she opened up a lot more i think
she's definitely a private person
sometimes it takes a little i i really
respect that i'm the opposite of private
i kind of just you know
i fart and i just tell you how i feel
and
but uh katie's uh katie's really amazing
and um i had a lot of fun with her i had
a lot of fun
on her with this and we we told some
stories and uh
i think you're going to really enjoy
this one i think you're going to really
like katie cassidy if
you don't know who she is have a listen
and if you are excited just tell me to
shut the [ __ ] up
uh let's get inside of katie cassidy
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael
[Music]
rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
hi katie
you look sharp you look sharp uh
i don't feel sharp but it's good to know
that i look sharp
um also you're welcome finally here's
your face time why do you always like to
facetime
all right here we go here we go folks
she's interviewing me this is what
happened literally
there's somebody in your [ __ ] i think
is that your sister
hey mrs was your sister taking a poop
what's she doing there she by the way it
was you might as well have walked tell
her she might as well have just
walked out instead of trying to duck
when there's nothing to duck behind
if you guys watch the video she creeps
out of the bathroom probably
that's hilarious she leaves she's going
to go no no it's great it's great
hi olivia bye olivia that's a nice name
olivia is it olivia cassidy
uh it's not olivia cassidy although
olivia cassidy is not a bad name
olivia cassidy in uh-huh maybe i'll
consider that let me get back to your
question
when i facetime you all right i facetime
everybody that's just my mo
it's like people i don't facetime i'm
like listen
i like to see the person i'm talking to
i could leave them there i could laugh i
could go do
things like on the phone i can't connect
because i have 80d so for some reason
facetime's a little bit better for me
does that make any sense
it does i understand if you were
somebody who
i i'm not actually um
this might sound weird but i'm not
actually the most social
person yeah i know i know that so i just
sometimes i just don't really want to
talk to people sometimes i just want to
like all the time all the time katie
let's be honest
all the time you're a private person i
get it and that was just
you know be with myself and my thoughts
and just
get all deep we met in australia
if you remember oh yeah we did why do
you say it like that
because australia was
the most chaos at least for me
chaotic uh trip for that uh
why was it so chaotic for you because i
really love going to australia in
supernova i mean
i can't remember i got sick oh yeah and
i was supposed to be training
and i brought my best friend with me oh
he's the best um he he came he trained i
was
like under all this pressure because i
was supposed to turn into this superhero
and i was
i don't know all over the place you were
training for supernatural
for uh i'm sorry arrow yeah yeah right
right so it wasn't a great experience
but you like the khan you like the
people you just
oh my gosh i love meeting people and i
love traveling but
in terms of you know when i i guess it's
because for the last
also and it's just not just you uh the
last eight years being on arrow and in
vancouver and go go go on weekends and
just not ever
not really having time for myself to
just be
just quiet and that's what's interesting
at least
about this year because
i haven't stopped since i've been since
i was 17 years old
and working and traveling and just
you know and i you know i i just needed
like
your time you time yeah yeah katie
this what you just said to me i don't
know if i could have survived because
i am barely you know i'm starting to get
together now
and get myself together late in life
okay so i can't imagine
at 17 being thrusted coming from a
family of you know
i mean i know you're you're estranged
from your father but at the same time
he's still
you know david cassidy was your father
bob we don't get into it too much but
like
it's let alone being a child at 17. i
couldn't imagine having someone famous
in a famous family
and then you just non-stop till now when
do you suddenly go
oh god i'm effed up or do you just go oh
i'm
completely together or i don't know
because i know that i probably would not
have made it if i was successful that
early
yeah here's the thing okay i think that
people
i had a really different upbringing than
most people know of
um people make you know assumptions and
i actually didn't meet my father until i
was in fourth grade and i grew up with
my mother and stepmother and
sisters and i was always very different
in and not in any way other than i love
to paint and i love to be alone i love
to build things i'd love to be artistic
and
that gene came from the cassidy side of
my family and when i actually met my dad
and then we did end up having a great
relationship
um for a period of time
i realized
how much like him and that side of the
family i am
and it sort of made me feel like okay
i'm not weird or different like i i this
is like
also where i belong and that's like
because i always thought felt different
and weird because i like to
be alone sometimes anyways so i
actually when i you know i ended up
moving out when i was 17 and my pa
i decided to pursue
acting and and instead of going to
college i just
i wasn't ever into subjects in school
other than
theater really um right so i
you know my parents were like okay if
you're
not we're not gonna help you you're on
your own so at 17 i literally
busted my ass i moved out i mean
there's a period of time where i did end
up going uh
i ended up going bankrupt and having to
call my mom and have her buy me
groceries
bankrupt and how old how old are
bankrupt
i was 19.
how do you go bankrupt at 19 when you i
have look when i was 19 i was bankrupt
i just had made enough money to have
like my own tiny little apartment and
i just focused on acting and realized
this was like my means of survival
and i've been on my own and it's
something i'm really proud of because
i've built
what i have on my own you know yes i
come from the cassidy family and my last
name
is cassidy and i feel so connected to
them and love them so much but i
didn't actually grow up with them um
and i built everything i had myself so i
like
but i love working too so i don't know i
think your question was how
does that happen how does it someone go
fast yeah i mean at 19 most people are
broke anyway so at 19 you had some money
because you were working pro
you were i guess you were working before
that you saved enough money you went on
your own you got an apartment
you were getting money from acting and
then yes and i had done a little bit of
i mean
a little bit of modeling like
when i was younger why do you laugh
because you're a beautiful person
i i said person because i don't want to
fit you to think i'm hitting on you
i don't know anyways uh i was like for
mervin's or
like kmart and uh
i mean it's just like embarrassing it's
not embarrassing it's part of your life
that's what you do we do why am i
screaming anyways uh yeah i had
gotten a little bit of money to get
myself into an acting class and own my
own apartment
and you know i had to hustle a bit
too you know i look at you and i hustled
a lot i told you i was
literally in my car driving around los
angeles with like
like a crazy person going from audition
to audition to audition
and changing in my car for like
a line in
like which i was so grateful and so
because it was
putting food i was putting food on
myself wow
i'm like yeah for one line you'd be
sitting your car going over the line
do you remember any of the one-liners
that you'd go into
gosh i don't hey jeff talk to you later
how could i say that a hundred ways i
know um but here we are and now
i have yeah this year oh you said how
why
do you think you know do i go i'm so
[ __ ] up it's like
no i mean look we're all [ __ ] up
in our own way um and it's just sort of
embracing
who you are and what that is and what
what works for you
i think you know what's weird is i
always say how f'ed up i am and then
other people like you're not that effed
up
and i'm like you don't know me you don't
know what go
oh i drop f-bombs i'm just trying to be
better because i have a friend joe who's
always f-bombing and i'm like
here's the thing i'm going to tell you
something so i just beat myself though
i hope no you could [ __ ] you could you
could [ __ ] off
wait you could completely f-bomb
alter myself to have this conversation
here's the thing my buddy john
name dropped john heater he's a good
friend of mine very close friend we
watch horror movies and i love his
family and they're mormons and they
don't like they're not like
you know the people think uh all mormons
are fundamentalists which they're
you know this group of that you know
have uh uh polygamists and all these
things and that's just not the case they
give
mormons a bad name but he's a wonderful
guy he doesn't sit there and go you
should be in one
he just has this and he's you know he
does his thing and so
they don't swear and i think it rubbed
off on me a little bit because he's
always going oh
that's f'd oh that's completely f did
she just show her t's
you know so it's kind of funnier to me
to just go
oh my god f off please
anyway um so look we're all f'ed up
we're all like
you know and people will say i bet that
they say that about you if they don't
know you you go oh
she seems so sweet she's so nice i don't
know why
but anybody who comes from a a family of
success and i know that your father
wasn't
around in the beginning and you had a
little bit of a relationship then it
kind of went awry
you know but that's gotta be tough on a
girl on a little girl or a little boy
to be in fourth grade and go do you ever
go where's dad where's dad what's going
on with that or
you know that's the thing i have i have
it's so interesting i have three dads is
the truth
um and i have a stepdad
that my mother married um
when i was four who
raised me and he he's wonderful and
you know he definitely taught me that's
where my drive he's he's an er doctor
and i saw growing up i watched
him and i think that side
of my brain of like being driven and
having goals and having ambition
that comes from him um the creative side
so i feel like
i'm lucky because i'm sort of well
balanced because the creative side comes
from my biological father
um and
the other side that you know my other
dad
is my sister's dad who he emotionally
was always there
for me and treated me like his own
daughter when i he had no reason to do
that and he
so i feel really fortunate you're a
culmination
you know holidays are a freaking
nightmare for me because you're running
around again
here i am like going to see everybody i
was
talking to my friend last night um he
has a similar family situation
and he gets so stressed out in the
holidays because he's trying to go to
but that's just family and that's just
that's you know what though
i call it selfishness and here's what
i'm going to say i know your family's
great you go around but i'm going to
talk about mine
the fact that and i don't want it to
happen but like
for a long time now i have to see my mom
but i have to see my sister separately
then i have to see my dad separately
then i have to see my gran
it's all these people my brother adam
can't see him with my mother can't see
him
gotta see my sister i've gotta make all
these trips and i have to fly across the
country i've stopped doing it
yeah it's like f off get get together
figure it out
whatever either either all come together
or
again it's like if you have that one day
at a
on a you know having christmas day
or christmas time to myself when i'm
running around working non-stop like
i don't want to then have my holidays
spent running around work you know
seeing everybody non-stop so
i for two or three years
just would go to miami and like have a
vacation of like
yeah yeah before you freak out
well you're a loner too you've talked
about that you like to be alone you
don't you get overwhelmed is that what
it is you get overwhelmed around do you
get overwhelmed on sets
with other people around yeah it's
actually i get it's interesting because
i do get i get overwhelmed around people
a lot of people i pick up people's
energy like i
um i don't know am i overwhelming you
right now oh good good good just want to
make sure
no but it's interesting because when i
know somebody and i feel like safe with
them
it's not an overwhelming thing i'm like
oh like
it's good good um but
a lot like crowds and stuff yeah it's
tough when it's on set
i've learned to block when we're like
you know rolling i i'm able to block out
the noise and
the people like i don't know but i
definitely try to like isolate
and go i don't mean isolate like i'll
try to go in sets that we're not using
that another one did
and just sort of like where's katie
freeze
does anyone see katie she's on the uh
the office set she's
she wants to be alone she's gathering
her thoughts do you think people
perceive you as standoffish at times i
i'm not i'm saying
b because you are so like inside
yourself wait what yes
and i think that 100 and
i don't know i grew up in a lot of chaos
you know um for whatever you know
without getting into it too much but it
was just at times chaotic
and i definitely think my spirit is more
quiet creative like i love i love
writing um
again love drawing sorry now i'm losing
my train of thought what was your
question
well you know do people perceive you as
can they perceive you or do you think
they can perceive you as someone who is
standoffish or whatever when you're
really not you're just kind of like
in your own head yeah um
and that thank you so in high school
and in middle school actually in middle
school i was bullied
by girls and in high school that were
older than me and i
didn't understand why well also another
thing that
i guess they call it resting [ __ ] face
i don't know
um but i guess i remember this girl
came up to me and like got in my face in
the bathroom and was like
you were getting looking at us and
giving us dirty looks or something and i
was like
what and i couldn't quite figure it and
then i realized i wasn't
doing anything other than the sun
11th grade i was bullied by these girls
because also i was really quiet and i
was really
i was i had like my little group of
friends but i was
yeah i think people perceived it as my
being
can we i wasn't being [ __ ] i used to
be quiet
sometimes like daydreaming i don't know
are you squinting at me looking like a
[ __ ] face at me
no the sun it hurts my eyes it's
directly on me here
you switch positions look at your face
oh god you're [ __ ] looking
um yeah so you you said that you know
your
things were so crazy when you were wrong
when you were wang
when you were young like what was like
what's one thing you could tell me that
to give me some insight as to the
craziness that
um happened in your life like something
you can remember like oh like i could
tell you stories i go
oh i remember when this happened with my
dad and my mom was upstairs talking to
this
one dude on the phone that she wasn't
talking
to right um so there was this time when
i was in high school
well there was a few times
okay so there was this one time in high
school i had this boyfriend who
i was a freshman
he was a junior and
his ex-girlfriend was a sophomore
and as a junior he would leave campus
this was my first like
boyfriend my high school sweetheart
he would go off campus for lunch
so these [ __ ] girls
we're friends the sophomore girls were
friends with junior girls and they
hated me because i was dating a junior
guy and i was a freshman
oh my gosh the drama um they waited till
i got
went into the bathroom by myself like
away from my friends
and three of them came in and like
pushed me against
one of the stalls and i obviously was
like completely caught off guard
and they were like you told
i'm not going to say name excuse me uh
you told insert name here you told angie
kramer
he's allowed to come to my birthday
party and i literally
i that was my reaction
i was like wait what are you guys
are we is it is this happening is this
hot
as a freshman i'm like this is a real
thing oh my god and then she slapped you
what and none of my friends really did i
don't remember the exact conversation my
friends really
didn't know and they were just totally
being
i don't remember what back and forth
went on well they didn't hit you did
they
no they didn't hit me um but one of my
friends eventually
like came in and was like leave her
alone blah blah blah
and i just remember like and then i
cried
i've tried to stand up i'm trying to
stand up for myself damn it
inside of you is brought to you by
butcher box guys i just got this box
full of stuff and i'm going to show it
to you
i couldn't believe the amount of amazing
food that i got
look at this raised by family farmers
pork committed to sustainable and humane
practices i got some pork
look at this look at these beautiful
chicken breasts right here i mean
organic and free-range
chicken breasts okay they sent me
ground brief ground brief they sent me
ground beef raised without antibiotics
butcher box knows what's going on and
it's hard it's hard to find
um antibiotic free and the free range
and you go to the deli or you go to the
grocery store and they don't have the
things that that you want that you we
want to eat as healthy as possible in
this world and
all the gmos and all the crap that you
gotta look out for
butcher box brings it to your doorstep
man
i i have not been this excited since i
opened an atari back in 1981
i opened this box and it's got pork and
short ribs and bacon and
i'm like i've done it i've made it
it's such an incredible idea and butcher
box really just nailed it
every month butcherbox ships a curated
selection of high quality meat right to
my house no added antibiotics or
hormones
each box has 9 to 11 pounds of meat
enough for 24 individuals packed fresh
shipped frozen vacuum
sealed so it stays that way and i can
customize my box or go with one of
theirs either way i
i get what i want man butcher box is a
no-brainer ryan
it's the best meat shipped right to your
door which means one less trip to the
grocers
options like 100 grass-fed and finished
beef free-range organic chicken
heritage pork wild-caught alaskan salmon
and sugar nitrate-free bacon it's the
way
meat should be ryan i agree butcher box
is the most affordable and convenient
way to get healthy
humanely raised meat with butcher box
you get the highest quality meat around
for just six dollars a meal and they
even have free shipping nationwide
except alaska in hawaii
for a limited time butcher box is now
offering new members
two new york strip steaks and one pack
of bacon for free
in your first box wow just go to
butcherbox.com
inside that's butcherbox.com
inside to get two new york strip steaks
and one pack of bacon for free
in your first box butcher box
inside of you is brought to you by true
underdog podcast
raised in a trailer park with no clear
path to success
kicked out of high school multiple times
faced with becoming a father in his
teens
jason waller is the definition of a true
underdog
after hearing the words no or you can't
too many times
he unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies
with his most recent venture power home
solar
skyrocketing on a path to becoming a
billion-dollar
enterprise join us as waller a four-time
entrepreneur of the year winner
shares motivational tips and inspiring
stories
and business building lessons from the
ground up he shares his life experiences
and those of his high profile guests to
help
others better themselves as waller will
tell you there is no elevator to success
that climb only happens one step at a
time
let every true underdog podcast be that
step that elevates you
scared money won't make money learn
about failure
learn about entrepreneurship learn about
never quitting or making excuses
it's real it's raw it's motivational
check out true underdog podcast at
trueunderdog.com
or anywhere you get your podcasts inside
of you is brought to you by
better help uh you know it's easy for me
to talk about these guys because i get
therapy so i could relate so i could
tell you about therapy and uh
as we know a lot of people refuse to
take therapy or get help because
they're too much of a man or it's just
uh
those times folks they're they're our
cake
our cake spell that one
um it's important it's important to talk
about your problems
things that are bothering you because
what happens is as i know
it bottles up and it keeps just kind of
overwhelming you until you
start to see physical um
[Music]
problems mental problems um it all has
to
leave somewhere you know it has to leave
the body and it it's just a tough thing
to go through anxiety depression
and uh with better help you don't need
to suffer anymore and if you're
worried about privacy they're they're
incredibly private incredibly
professional
and uh you know they could hook you up
with a therapist within 48 hours that's
how fast
you can get this done to talk to someone
if you don't want to do a video chat you
can just talk
it's up to you it's in your hands to get
some help during these tough times
we don't always have a lot of people to
talk to and sometimes we don't want to
talk to anybody about some of the
personal stuff that we
we have inside of us better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy you
know that's true and you can start
communicating with your therapist in
under 48 hours
join the millions of people who are
seeing what therapy is really about
it may or may not be for you but it's
worth looking into because you
are your greatest asset this podcast is
sponsored by better help
and inside of you listeners get 10 off
their first month
at betterhelp.com inside
that's better h-e-l-p dot com
slash inside get some help
you know but maybe it gave you all that
uh confidence
and drive to become a competitive
cheerleader i know you're going to kill
him you're like i'm not talking about
cheerleading
here's the only reason i only we don't
have to talk about i know now it's the
resting [ __ ] face is the sun in your
eyes katie
i believe it is now listen listen real
quick i'm losing internet connection oh
really really i'm just gonna say this i
watched it
can't don't you damn
we're losing oh look at your cat look at
that little cat
carlos was like oh my gosh she got so
stressed out i knew it you on an impact
carlos is like please don't talk about
the cheerleading
i don't think i know please don't talk
about the cheerleading katie really
hates it
look how cute you guys have to see this
cat look how cute that little kitty is
but i watched that show cheer of the
documentary and i was blown away and i
thought competitive cheer
that's hard and you're throwing up were
you like one of those that was thrown up
in the air and did flips and [ __ ]
yeah that's did you ever fall and break
a hand
uh i definitely fell it baskettos is
like
you know competitive cheerleading is
actually really
i watched so mature and it's really
insane
uh is it competitive you
go through and what you put your body
through and
yeah these you know basket tosses to
doing
back tucks in the air and then landing
in a cradle
trusting your your base are going to be
there to catch you and actually one of
my sisters
she and she's my older sister she
we did it together and she was always i
was a flyer and she was always a base
and it was actually really cute and nice
that that was something
she was my base hey you shared it was
like you had to trust her
oh always it's all coming back to me now
that we're talking about this i have to
share another one go ahead okay so same
situation
but i'm in middle school
boyfriend uh
i was this seventh grader he was
a ninth grader um
[Music]
but these
were girls like you don't
oh you don't mess with you
yeah no i also was like
a little scared almost to date this guy
because he was a little sketchy and you
know he live and learn whatever
so he
oh she found out they went they were
they were also in ninth grade excuse me
and they went to a different school
though
they went to agora high school and
when they found out we were dating
they started i remember
calling me and this girl
called me and was like
i swear to god if you don't break up
with insert name here john candy
i'm gonna [ __ ] beat your ass i'm
gonna [ __ ] i swear to god
she said she was gonna kill me and
were getting off the phone and that this
was obviously years and years
100 years ago can't get away with that
[ __ ] now
but you know kids are nuts so
i started freaking out and i told my mom
i was like genuine i was scared
and my mom was like my mom was like oh
well guess what i know the principal of
that school
and i'm gonna guess what's gonna happen
i'm gonna call him right now
and i'm gonna tell him and what he did i
guess
is i mean they got suspended they
brought them out of called them out of
class
the next day the two of them there was
two girls
who were calling me and saying this
nasty [ __ ] to me and they brought them
in the principal's office and
i guess my mom was there with two police
officers
and i guess they just had a talking to
uh
wow but they got suspended for
i think or maybe even expelled i don't
know either
two weeks or two months and they also
had to call and apologize to me
i mean it was that's what i mean girls
are really nasty i don't understand why
people don't just support one another
and lift each other up because we're all
beings
let me tell you something katie that
story could have went
really south because in today's world or
any world
you hear that story where like you're
like oh my god i'm embarrassed my mom's
taking care of it and now the guys are
like you know what
now they're that's a movie then they're
plotting to say this as
much as i wanted to
you know fight my mom when i was a
teenager she did
that was dope jerry was it sherry cherry
sherry yeah that was that was cool right
i mean it was cool but i almost wish
that she knew an investigator who just
goes
hey you're never gonna talk to her again
or
i'm taking your family down and then you
never know about it and these girls are
just really nice to you like hey katie
how are you
oh my god you don't have a resting [ __ ]
face it's just looks like a beautiful
sunset
but i didn't know that that happened hey
let's get into your career a little bit
because
you have you've had a great career i
mean so far and you're young so you have
a
huge career ahead of you and i know
you're very work oriented and you're an
artist
you do so many different things and i
always feel like in a way
we're like in a sense that you don't
stop you don't give
yourself time to just decompress and you
um whereas also whereas also
terrible english but like i think you
also get into things because you're
a passionate person like you'll get into
a relationship it'll be
hot and heavy and fun and whatever and
then whatever whereas i'm very
timid not timid but very i keep my
everything back like whoa whoa
whoa i've seen dysfunction in my life
and i'm not going to get in jump into
anything
so i think that's where we differ maybe
a little bit but do you think
that um can you be present
in a particular show and think this is
where i need to be or are you always
thinking i'm better than this i need to
do a show that's better
i need to be a movie that's better or
can you be like i'm going to be yeah
explain your
your work ethic i am very much living in
the moment so
in fact so much that i can't plan ahead
that unless it's work related in my
personal social life
my personal life especially social life
i don't like to have a schedule
like what i'm gonna do on a tuesday at 3
p.m i'm not sure
i'm going to figure out what how i feel
when i wake up on a tuesday
and let's talk then and i get it if you
have a schedule that's cool
but i as much as i can i try and live in
the moment
and i think that's where people should
like
they say the the past cost living in the
past causes depression
living in the future and
living in the present the present is a
gift
you know my therapist i've said it
before as i see he goes stand up
or he stood up i didn't stand up he goes
you got your left foot in the past
you got your right foot in the future
and again he just pretended he was
holding his dick
and he goes and you're pissing on the
present that's what we're doing here
michael
he's not my therapist anymore but i like
the analogy
uh you know but i will say that well
first of all what is your the so far
your favorite job you've had whether
it's small but whatever the most fun you
had where you felt you were at your best
i i mean arrow was wonderful
um but again like they gave a lot
for my character to do and i definitely
throw myself into whatever it is that
i'm working on
whether it be acting
you know i go i go for it
uh and i just dive into it whether it be
acting writing directing
you know and it's interesting because
i'm learning a lot more about myself
especially having this year of just like
woosa calmness and stillness
um writing is something i've always
had this like incredible
passion and drive and just like that's
what i
since i was a kid i used to journal
until
my mother read my journal that's why i
don't write
journals we work through these things um
i stopped writing however during this
pandemic i've been writing so much and
i'm
like and being in this like in flow is a
thing
and it's just that's what i mean like
you're in
this you're so present in in
there i don't know stories that's just
you're in control that's why you like it
you're in control of every like
when you're writing something it's your
thoughts your heart you
everything goes into that i think you
like that it's your voice but also
it's not just your voice it's for you're
telling that
a story hopefully telling a story
to people to better the more to better
the
world in in sharing story
through your vision through the way you
see it whatever
the story is that you're telling i love
that yeah
so it's really cool yeah finding your
voice like you know learning how to
figuring that out like it's a whole
process and it's really cool
so i i found out you know directing is
another thing i have such an
incredible passion for and getting you
know i directed an episode of arrow um
this last season and it was
i was on cloud nine i mean i
made my days and some and i was like oh
gotta do this you gotta do it like i
just knew
i was so prepared though and i'm so
grateful for the warner brothers
director's program because
i went through it it was a three-month
really intense program but they
i i was just i was like completely
overly prepared and
it was just an amazing experience and
and i realized
i it's not i'm not just an actor and i'm
not just a writer i'm not just a
director i think i'm just a creator and
storyteller however that outlet is i
think
doing is is more like you took a class
for three months which is great but
you know when i remember doing a pilot
i i remember shooting an episode of
smallville directing and
what i learned in that 10 days was an
absolute crash course in everything and
then shooting like a short
like doing like but like when you said
that like that warner brothers directors
program i'm interested do they still do
that
oh my gosh and can i tell you you should
absolutely take it it was like it was
life-changing
it literally you meet the most
incredible people they still
it's only i think 12 people in a class
i'll i'll
give you is it expensive uh i don't
think so
to you maybe oh please
stop hey name this actor this next part
is very difficult
they're going to take you i want you to
take it
[Laughter]
you were in that movie did you work you
worked with him yeah he was lovely
i always wanted to work with him oscar
schindler i could have with this one
i could have saved one more jew i with
this watch
i i couldn't have saved i cry every time
i think about it he's a class act
oh man when my father passed away
i got my agent received a handwritten
note from liam and it had been
i don't remember 10
years since i shot taken yeah and he
wrote on his own stationary this
hand written note that just was you know
my condolences i'm so sorry you know
it was just so classy and he was just
and when we were shooting he was so
professional and it was just
it was a great experience that's awesome
when you're heroes or when people that
you really admire
actually come through in a such a humane
way that you're like
wow this is what i always wanted these
people who i
you know i liked to to be and when you
see that
that's awesome i love that yeah it was
yeah it was so great
you know and that had to be hard for you
i mean i know obviously but
you know because i read the quote i'm
sure you've you've heard it but it's
like
you know your dad was quoted as and this
wasn't that long ago right
i mean 2017 i never had a relationship
with katie i wasn't her father
biologically
uh you know biologically i was but i
didn't raise her he said he was proud
of you and you were so talented was it
hard to hear that or
were um no i mean look that was the
truth i
chose not and this is the truth
my father you know
he had demons as we all do
um and you know i think that
fame and as child fame
i mean i've been in therapy my whole
life thank you
good for you dr shirley um
i think it can really mess you up and i
think
i chose at some point you know later
once i was
twenty four
i think maybe 25
it just wasn't healthy for me because
you know he was struggling with
you know alcohol and and it just i chose
at some point that it wasn't you know it
wasn't
it wasn't healthy and
when he was in the hospital and i had
heard
that he was i'm now going off track no
no you're not
you're not going off track you're just
talking ultimately about
you know like when he said these nice
things about you and then of course
you know it was hard to deal with you
know the loss of him but you you had
i guess you're saying you heard that he
was in the hospital yeah so
he had said these things to me but what
that didn't like
it didn't hurt me that he said that i
mean it was true but at one point we
were really close friends when i was
younger
you know he was more like my best friend
i remember i would talk to him every
night for hours
um and that was years ago but anyway so
when
he went i when he was in the hospital i
went
and my uncle was there and and
he was in a coma already and it was such
a beautiful
moment my uncles were there my brother
was there
and we all were surrounding him
you know together and
and he passed and i just got emotional
see now you're making me emotional i
just just just like i could just
you know sense that like ultimately
just being with your family and
everybody that loved you know that was
part of your blood
was all there and it was somewhat
relieve
it was a relief in a way
it was it's hard to
it's hard to describe it because
i was so estranged from them not my
brother
and not my uncles but
him for about seven years and i
i think it was like almost like a
forgiveness
is what it was like for all of us
because i you know i think he had
difficulties with my uncles
and i certainly think you know with my
brother
at times i think it was just this moment
of
i i don't know like yeah i guess like a
relief like he could be in peace
you know um
because i think being a child star
really
was hard for him
inside of you is brought to you by
echelon yes you're gonna get to see my
little video in a minute of me working
out it's one of my favorite things
ryan's edited
uh i love echelon you know everybody's
talking about their bikes and their
rowers and their things and uh
with echelon i realized wow i could have
the best stuff
for a lot cheaper than these other
jokers and that's pretty
damn sweet it is true that they did send
me a rower i
row row rows and bomb every day and
there's nothing that feels better than
rose and mom i love these guys over at
echelon
and uh when it comes to getting uh or
staying in shape nothing feels as good
as that feeling of accomplishment which
we all know hitting your fitness goals
feeling great about yourself it's
important and i worked out this morning
i did the rower
and i did the mirror and i did some
boxing on the mirror and uh
i honestly felt great it made me feel
better and that's just a fact
echelon offers the next generation of
connected fitness bikes
fitness mirrors rowing machines and
their echelon stride smart
treadmill no matter what your favorite
fitness activity echelon gives you a fun
and challenging workout from the comfort
of your home the ex-7s is echelon's
latest state-of-the-art innovation that
takes cycling to the next level
the ex7s connected bike is built with
performance flexibility and durability
in mind
the ex-7s is the bike for competitors
at heart their world-class instructors
will motivate you with thousands of
daily live and on-demand studio level
classes always available when you need
them
right now you could try any echelon
fitness equipment at home
for 30 days 30 days to try it out i
don't know why
if you're sitting there you wouldn't say
well let's just see what it does and on
the 29th day if you want to give it back
you give it back but i have a good
feeling about this one go to
echelonfit.com
inside of you that's e c h e
l o n fit dot com
slash inside of you echelon
inside of you is brought to you by geico
i mean what are you guys thinking i i i
just like i i
talk about this all the time but i like
easy i like simple i like uh it's a
breeze with geico
maybe that should be their new thing
because
uh you know i've talked about this
before but you get the insurance stuff
man when you have to get insurance
policies from different companies and
you're like oh well this one is cheaper
and then this one's
well i can't get them all cheap and all
together at the same place
it's called a bundling policy folks
that's what that
is and geico has bundling policies that
you should uh
check out for sure whether you rent a
home
or a an apartment or you buy a home
you have mortgages it's tough you got to
pay homeowners insurance and you got to
pay
then you got your auto it's a bunch of
crap if you ask me
it's crap to have to pay all these
different people so make it easy
and uh geico makes it easy to bundle
your homeowners or renters insurance
along with your auto policy it's a good
thing because you already have so much
to do around your house
and you don't want to do this other
tedious stuff right go to geico
go to geico.com get a quote see how much
you could save it's geico easy visit
geico.com today
that's geico.com even a rosenbomb can do
it
you know i remember going to see my
favorite music of all time which i think
i told you is
uh blood brothers on broadway with i
think shawn
david and patrick and patrick was on
i believe he was on smallville as well i
worked with patrick and
he was so delightful and so amazing to
work with and i just i
you know i remember seeing that musical
and if you had to
if you took a camera in front on a dolly
and you panned or you just the dolly
went from left to right and started with
my
father my father would have been like
this just like uh-huh
uh-huh you know stone-faced then my
brother just kind of picking his nose
not giving a crappy and
then passed him then go to my mom
hysterically crying
and then to me crying hysterically so
that tells you a lot my brother was a
lot like my dad
my dad eric was my dad's favorite my mom
i was just sort of an emotional mess i
was kind of like a
mix between them and i remember seeing
that show and i saw it twice i
i but i just i loved it so much
and i just was like i i really wan i
wanted to become
more of an actor i want to become better
a better actor
and i remember just loving your family
and that they were so dynamite it was
did you ever see it i didn't i didn't
but isn't that such an incredible
feeling
um when you're watching i remember anne
haish
in proof
i saw her in new york when she
was improved and her performance
i was so moved and inspired by her
and that you're right like i remember
being like i
was like and i need to go into all the
acting classes i can actually
yeah yeah the best i don't know how i
just i needed this is what i need to do
i'm supposed to be doing this i have to
go now
right now yeah yes um
it's just like a cool feeling when when
you're inspired by that so cool
thank you i mean that's such a well it's
true it's true i still have
i'll you know i'll send it to you i
think i have a uh play bill
i don't know if they signed it or not
but i have the play bill in there i have
in fact my grandfather
kept every playville playville playbill
from every play
from back to the 30s he's got everything
you can imagine
funny thing happened on the way to the
forum like and he's got them all and
when he passed
last november which was the hardest
thing i've ever had to go through
um my grandmother said take them like
what do you mean he's like
take the play bills what am i going to
do with them we know you're the only
actor in the family
take take the play bills so i have to
play bill
she's uh he was he was marvelous um
this is from my patrons who are
wonderful who support the show and if
you guys want to join patreon's
patreon.com inside of you but these are
questions from them that you know you
could ask or uh
or not this is rapid fire [ __ ] talking
with casey
what [ __ ] talking with katie cassidy
really fast
well you could go fast or you can go
slow or you can go pass okay
rozzy broder when you first read the
script for taken what did you think of
it
i want to go to paris good call i
thought it was awesome
and i literally was like uh i was
actually originally supposed to
i auditioned to play his daughter it was
between myself and maggie grace
i got the best friend role and i was
still like okay great
liam neeson's in this movie and it looks
it's freaking awesome and i want to go
to paris
tiffany ireland love her been a fan
since she was ruby on supernatural
wasn't a question tiffany but
thank you she thanks you am i correct
katie say that again
you're welcome yeah oh thank you it'd be
the
answer not your welcome oh thank you
thank you well you said thank you i'm
confused oh yeah i am too
steph alexander is green arrow and the
canaries moving forward i hadn't heard
about it anymore
i'm not sure nico what's the most
amazing adventure you ever have been on
it's not australia she was sick oh my
gosh
i went to thailand that was incredible i
went to africa
that was oh my gosh the africa story
it's too long of a story but basically i
was in africa
help malawi it's a non-profit
organization
out of um malawi
in this small little town i totally just
watched how to say that and
help educate you know help is help
help educate love and protect is what it
stands for
um but it's for children in africa
who don't have you know the supplies or
education
or resources to
each drink you know this school there's
like a thousand children that you know
basically we raised money to
build in a health clinic and we i went
there and built a garden for them and i
showed them how they could recycle water
while they're washing their hands
over the plants and we made show them
how to make peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches and
dance with that i mean it was just such
an incredible experience to go there
and see these kids you have to go back i
could tell how much it meant to you have
to go back
i need to go back you do i can see
that's important to you
you don't understand these kids are
they've never seen a camera before and
you just realize
like how they don't
they are like they've never seen i
remember i had my
camera and i could lay back my the photo
for them and they had never seen a photo
of themselves i think it's
probably a good thing that they they're
on a lot of cameras around them
it's probably mentally healthy these
poor kids and
if 95 of them are hiv positive
yeah maybe i'll go with you yeah we
should totally go
let's talk about it anyway so
where we stayed was also insane uh
i stayed at this lodge that was
had you had to take a boat by the way
we'll talk about
how long it takes to get to malawi and
you're doing all means of transportation
so we've
taken a boat you're taking the jeep
you're taking a plane you're taking a
train
my back already hurts so i we're in
giant tents and there's only like seven
of them on this giant property
where the sanctuary is next door
and there are alligators outside of my
front door
because it's on swamp and so all night
long you hear
and i'm gonna they're jaws granted it
was a nice tent
there's no air conditioning it's like
104 high ceilings i have a guy who's
staying outside the tent
overnight with a rifle uh
there isn't a toilet otherwise at the
kid's school there's a hole in the
floor um i feel so bad for him
uh oh yeah an elephant one night
escaped the sanctuary and i woke up in
the morning and there was a
[ __ ] elephant footprint outside the
front oh
and the guy with the rifle who's
supposed to be my bodyguard
here is like yeah
i i was about if he had stepped a little
closer i was going to have to take
because he would have smushed
leanne pritchett if you could only put
one thing on your bucket list what would
it be
oh i'm dying to go to india and just
i just want to go i mean there's so many
things but i want to go to india and i
want
to help i want to
i yeah i just want to go to india and i
want to help
people good steph alexander just the
last part of this question
how do you deal with hateful comments on
like facebook and all that stuff how do
you deal with it dude
i don't why i don't read my messages
often why
because people are [ __ ] and i don't
want to feel not everybody there's a lot
of people that love you but
maybe unfortunately i also don't want to
get my head
people love me right i'd like to hear
so once in a while i'll read but i don't
engage i'm also like
you know what your negativity it's not
gonna bring me down
and i'm just gonna either don't deal or
i just you know
she's doing some nice arms i don't know
why people have to people this is me
just being like can't with the negative
energy of people it is so
toxic i know i know it can be but you
know what
i uh i just go oh oh that's a nice
message that's a person who's donating
to my charity
and then i just go oh that person's just
uh really hateful blocked okay next
person here we go
all right wow that person's sad did you
like working with stephen amell
um yes i love steven he actually
we have a really good well rapport
friendship
working relationship and here
is what here's why i think
stephen coming out of the gates this
was our conversation when we first met
stephen hi okay
if you [ __ ] this up
i will [ __ ] kill you oh my god don't
[ __ ] this up for us all right you're the
lead [ __ ]
don't become an [ __ ] and if you are
if you're gonna become an
[ __ ] i'm gonna let you let you know
you're being
an [ __ ] yeah okay and he he this is
like right
oh my god pilot i think or he might have
been a comic-con
i don't know but he of course started
cracking up
and i don't know it's like a
he becomes he's like kind of like a
brother in a way yeah i don't know
but he has respect for me and he we can
laugh at each other and i roll my eyes
at him and i've called him out and he's
called me out so
i love steven jack slater i got to ask
jack slater's question because i love
slater too
uh if you don't if you didn't take the
role of laurel lance black canary
what other dc or marvel role would you
have loved to have brought to life
hot woman you'd be a great cat woman you
are a catwoman
oh i know so i'm just putting it out
there into the universe
no sophie says sophie miller who
inspired you to get into acting
i have a feeling i know this i'm third
generation my
grandfather jack cassidy he played
superman on broadway
i think it was on broadway i think
pretty sure uh
he was an actor obviously my dad uncles
it's just
it's in the gene pool i was born this
way
i think just being a creator is in my
blood
do you ever get nervous acting with
certain actors or have you ever been
intimidated or have you ever been like
oh my god my voice is cracking or how do
you get out of that
last question yeah
uh i've been into no not by another
actor
i playing a lawyer
and going into a courtroom full and
doing
and having legal jargon and you're
giving your opening statement but you're
actually
bursting into a scene into the courtroom
like interrupting
and everybody in the courtroom turning
their head to see who opens the doors
and you walk in when they're
[ __ ] the guy you go and you stand
you're like i'm here i'm the lawyer
representing littleville
and i'm making my own statement and it's
all legal jargon
and it's like a two-page monologue
forget it yeah i wouldn't take the role
all of the actors and the leads are
there
watching sitting in the stands
i holy [ __ ]
i can tell you what scene it was did you
get through it like was it hard to get
through it did you like stumble
constantly
i had to stop and i started
hyperventilating i started having a
panic attack and i realized like i
i breathe you know i told the director i
was like look
and then you get in your head have you
gotten it you know and then you're like
oh then it's muscles
so i was like i'm trying to listen i was
like
michael i just give me a couple minutes
i just need to calm down
and i'll be fine i just i got insecure
with the dialogue and now i'm getting in
my head
and he was like it's fine just take a
breath
i got through it um but i was i remember
feeling like
flush red and sweating and like
yep been there oh my god and
seen and it looks great i remember so it
was happening like i was really like
i was just i couldn't get it out i
couldn't get the lines out one time and
i was getting nervous getting in my head
and i was looking at director i just
turned my head and a crew guy caught
eyes with me
like you know make eye contact with me
which which is okay i'm not christian
bale
i mean so you know i love the crew but
he looked at me and it
went like this he gave me the like like
like oh you don't you're [ __ ]
i was like no why did i have to see that
now i had to impress him and do the line
so
uh no the line so whatever this has been
a joy i'll talk to you after
thank hey thank you for allowing me to
be inside of you today on the show thank
you say
what you just said again i want to thank
you for being on the podcast and also
i want to say that you have no idea how
many people patrons and listeners
really get something from these real
stories that you tell like the story
about your dad or whatever it's just
relatable and it helps people so thank
you thank you for being open and awesome
thank you namaste
i like her stories when she was younger
yeah you know how she was kind of picked
on that was a relatable thing for me
yeah i like that she had nice things to
say about her her dad
at the end yeah because it was a it was
a tough relationship
but it was tough yeah yeah it was uh you
know i think we all have relationships
that are tough and
um when someone passes it's never that
easy but um
you know all you could say is i did the
best i could and if you can't you say
well i didn't do the best i could and um
i'm speaking on my behalf
but maybe i didn't do everything i could
but i did everything i could at that
time at that time that was the best i
could do you look back and you always
think i could have done this i could
have done that but in the moment
it's a different story so anyway thank
you katie cassidy for coming on the
podcast i finally got on the podcast
again sun spin uh the new album's out
best days you can get it on amazon and
itunes
and if you want to support the band and
win some sweet swag you just go to
instagram
type in sun spin band on instagram and
this uh this contest there's a contest
it only lasts for a couple of weeks so
make sure you uh you check it out today
we have a post that explains everything
uh over on instagram at sunspin band and
um you can also get merch and
book the band at sunspin.com
but uh get involved in the sweet swag
you're gonna love
the freaking merch that you win trust me
i have a feeling it might be a lunch box
one of them don't forget stage at
february 27th
two shows 2 p.m and 6 p.m pacific
standard time
zooms right after the show prizes we'll
play covers we get a lot of laughs
it's a connection it's uh back and forth
we
say comments we respond to them and we
sing and we have a great time stage you
go to stage.com
type in sun spin or you can also go to
sunspin.com
for all the information thank you for
listening as always
tuning in week after week those of you
that do that stick with me that stick by
my side
it goes a long way let me give a shout
out to the wonderful patrons who
do more than i ever expected anyone to
do
nancy d by the way i am wearing glasses
are you thinking that
you were probably thinking that at the
beginning of this podcast but i decided
to wear glasses because i didn't want to
put contacts in because my eyes were
tired
you sound smarter i'm sure they cannot
tell
i don't look smarter i sound smart
you can tell just by listening that
you're wearing
glasses thank you ryan here are the
patrons big
shout out you can look at their names
here as we go and you could be a name
too
on the podcast and get a shout out by
joining patreon.com inside of you
that's p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash
inside of you and uh join the wonderful
patron family there's a lot of great
things on there and
i hope you do here are the uh amazing uh
uh patrons nancy d mary b
leah s sarah v little lisa yukiko
jill e bryan h lauren g nicco p
robin s jerry w robert i jason w stephen
j
kristen k amelia o allison l jess j
lucas am raj raj see joshua d emily s
i also did a zoom with uh the top tiers
and so it was like 70 of us on a zoom i
posted it as well it was all of us
yapping and uh getting to know each
other more on the patreon
cjp samantha m jennifer and jackie p
stacy l
carly h gen s janelle b carey b tab with
the 272 not to be confused with that
with the two songs ashley ryan kimberly
e mikey marissa and
l supremo that's dan
jack s i just love saying it jackass
slater's like funny real funny ramirez
beth b
santiago m sarah f chad w liam p
roshan r rey a maya p miesha c
maddie s kendrick f ashley e shannon d
matt w belinda and kevin v
james r chris h a new should w
amy c dave h samantha s spider-man
chase sheila g rey
a h close i wasn't done oh you weren't
done
[Music]
uh alyssa c tabitha t amisha h
deb a tom and suzanne b bradley henry b
kdf le llano le leliana michelle k
marcus w got a few more here
all right hannah b michael s italia m
luke h john s andrew t
christie s claire m liz j laura l
chad b rochelle or is it rachel
it's rachel i'm gonna say rachel it's
rachel it's
rachel nathan e brandel
uh taylor k neil a marlin
meg k janelle p dan ann and jennifer
j thank you also a big shout out to
my charities of choice the ronald
mcdonald house of los
angeles if you ever want to donate
that's a great uh organization
foodonfoot.org i'm a 98 club member you
could be one too
i can't wait till the servings can
happen again where we can go and help
and
and do servings but a great organization
and echoes of hope
for um foster youth getting them off the
streets and giving them
the opportunities to uh be successful
and happy
like us are you happy ryan
i am happy what is happy what is happy
what is happy guys it's been a pleasure
it always is
uh uh write in at hello at
insideviewpodcast.com hello
insideoupodcast.com
and i don't check them right away and by
the way if you're buying merch and then
you send a message saying oh can i get
that in a
no i'm sending the merch out i don't
like check these messages and go oh they
wanted a picture signed to this person
if you don't make something i've done it
too and it's such a pain in the ass i
gotta rip open bags that i've packed
sometimes they're already sent i feel
bad just you know
when it says it's it's just yeah
you know what i mean just deal guys i
love you
dearly that's all i have to say thank
you for allowing me to be inside of you
from
ryan um here up in the hills of
california california yeah michael rose
by the house
yeah we love you and thanks for allowing
me to be inside you once more and you'll
wave to the camera ryan
thanks guys thanks for uh supporting
foreign
island